hello everyone and sorry about so many
videos in one day but it's not my fault
that do the English car obvious with the
two most interesting players on the
planet and well these are very important
games so this is the sixth game of their
match so for those of you who are just
tuning in two of the classical games
have been wrong then do the one the
first game of the rapids but Grisha was
able to retaliate so he equalized and
then in the shorter rapid control Grisha
was able to take the lead so here Duda
is in a very unpleasant must-win
situation he has the white pieces he has
to win now let's see what happens do
that with the white pieces opens with E
for this time sorry about that we have E
5 by Griff shock Knight to f3 Knight to
c6 Knight to c3 and Knight to f6 the
four Knights defense and Bishop to b5 by
do the Spanish variation of the four
Knights and here already very exciting
stuff for from ratio Green Knight the D
for the Rubenstein counter-attack so
inviting all sorts of ideas maybe maybe
you're interested in the juicy e5 pawn
maybe maybe we're interested in
capturing and d4 but I'll fry you know
do that aside for Bishop to a4 it's just
best not to give away your bishop here
if you go for something like Knight
captures on e5 then you don't really win
a pawn after Queen t7 attacks knight
Knight goes back and now a trade on b5
and now you just capture on e4 so
everything is perfectly fine for black
here
so of course Duda is not interested in
any unnecessary trades Knight to Bishop
to a4 he must win this game with c6
preparing d5 and now comes Knight
captures on e5 now the pawn can be
grabbed with d5 and now b3 by white and
interestingly in 2009 Vasily when she
had this position against Fabiana
Caruana in Beale and Bobby went for
Bishop to d6 here Chucky was able to win
that game but here we have Bishop to c5
and this is a new move into position so
already as a move 7 we have a completely
new game we have castles by Duda castles
by Ganesha and now comes King to h1 so
preparing f4 you don't want working on
g1 after this diagonal opens with Queen
to c7 attacking the knight and now f4
just attack
that defending the night and b5 pushing
the Bushra back Bishop to b3 and now a5
preparing a for to trap the bishops of
course a3 do the mix room for the bishop
on a two night capture son b3 Grigio
trades ones seek actress and now Bishop
to d4 so with ideas of capturing and c3
but also you could have plans on
capturing on e5
so tonight back to f3 putting pressure
on the bishop and now Bishop captures in
c3 so here if Duda would just capture
then agree she also wins the e4 pawn so
not interested in that do the place he
five and okay we have Bishop captures on
e5 you have to give give back at least
one piece so why not Bishop captures on
e5 f captures attacking the knight and
the Knight to d7 and here Bishop to f4
so Duda is able to keep the pressure
going still having some problems in
developing his LightSquared bishop and
the rooks we have Knight the c5 and now
comes Luke the c1 with an attack on the
knight Knight goes back to e six attacks
the bishop and the Queen to d2 c5
preparing c4 and the now comes d4 you
cannot capture as rook captures Queen so
we have C 4 by grip and then now Knights
to h4 with ideas of maybe getting the
Knight to f5 maybe you can get the night
over to d6 could be very nice
so Queen to d8 getting the Queen out of
out of the C file also attacking the
knight on h4 and here Bishop to g3
just getting the bishop out of the way
defending the knight for the moment I'm
not going to f5 right away and the now
comes Knight to g5 now Grisha wants to
get his knights to e4 with a nice attack
on the Queen and the bishop here we have
Knight back to f3 and the nice the e4
you can't really do anything about that
Queen to III and the now Bishop to f5 so
here with Bushra back the a1 Duda avoids
a more trays but it's always dangerous
to disconnect your looks like this so he
has to be very careful in doing so and
now look the c8 Greek finally gets his
rook into the game
we have h3 do the make some room for its
King and now h6 a Grisham does the same
nice to d2 and now comes
back to g6 as the bishop is now under
attack so Bishop to g6 and now Knight
captures on e4
we have Bishop captures on e4 and now
Bishop to d2 just connecting rooks again
developing the bishop we have looked the
c6 now with ideas of getting to recover
to g6 which would create a lot of
pressure on the g2 pawn so a four by
Judah and now rook to g6 of course you
have to defend g2 with rook to f2 and
now Queen to h4 adding another attacker
here so here there are a lot of
interesting ideas if the Queen ever
moves from the defense of the third rank
even Queen captures on h3 as Anna is an
idea so very unpleasant King to h2
taking care of the g3 square but also
not allowing Queen captures on h3 if the
Queen ever moves so look the b8 finally
defending the b5 pawn and now comes a
capture Sun b5 rook captures on b5 and
now B captures on c4
we have rook a person b2 by Grisha and
now you could go for C 5 C 5 is
definitely the way to go then it's a
race but it's not a favorable race for
Duda as he has to win this game for
example a 4 and now if c6 you can just
go Luke b3 and now White has problems
because the Queen cannot capture due to
Queen captures and f2 would be just
deadly you have to block and then just
route captures Bishop captures still the
Queen cannot capture and I will just
eliminate the pawn so not not all that
difficult to calculate that it's not not
the winning idea it's it might be the
best move but it's not it's it's not
easy to play the best move when you know
it's not a winning move so rooks eat the
f1 instead the doubling up on the F file
still it's no threat you cannot capture
here because just the route characters
and g2 so we should just continue is
pushing the passed pawn with a 4 and now
like I said if you if you capture the
point you're getting mated Roccat
foreseer check you move a discovered
check from the bishop whatever whatever
you play Queen captures and h3 let's say
is mate so here after a 4 we have g3
pushing the Queen back and now Queen
back to e7 Begley shook finally c5 now
and now rook the b3 now the B 3 square
is is even guarded so we have Bishop to
seat
you cannot move the Queen if you move
the Queen then just rook captures here
as a both of the rooks are attacking the
gt1 so Bishop c3 is a must but now a3
English continues pushing his past pawn
we have looked a 1 now Duda will try to
create some counter play against the a3
pawn and now rook the a6 adding or
putting a row behind a passed pawn of
course Queen 2 c1 and now comes f6
wanting to bust open the center so if
you capture here then you will also most
likely be able to eliminate all of the
pawns
so rook after a 2 but really just
captures on e5 he says it's not a
problem if you capture on a3 I'm just
gonna play rook captures here and if you
capture Queen to f6 wins the game for me
you will not be able to capture here
because Queen f2 check followed by Queen
2g to mate as the bishop slices all the
way here so this is this is one example
of a great bishop and also this is one
example of a terrible bishop but it's
often when you're in a must-win
situation that you will end up with
positions like these unfortunately so
better back the d2 by Judah and now he
captures on d4 and finally c6 do that
starts pushing his passed pawn
but now Queen to d6 now threatening
Queen captures and g3 this will be made
of course as the bishop still covers all
of the lights were so you cannot allow
this we have Bishop f4 by Judah now
covering the c7 square so hopefully c7
can be played but now just Queen
captures and c6 of course and Rishabh
will not allow this point to go forward
and here dude I just played capture
sandy31 a3 and I believe it was in this
position that Grisha will offer do the a
draw even though Duda is completely lost
in this situation but a girl issue
doesn't need Duda to lose this game as
he just needs a draw to win the feed a
Grand Prix in Hamburg and well Duda will
also you know save some rating points
maybe maybe you know not not lose so
much in the match and you know it's the
gentlemanly thing to do plus you can
always blunder something so why not take
a draw and win the Grand Prix so it was
in this position on move 45 that the
players agree to a draw even though if
you play it out or move or to let's say
you capture rook
a captures rook captures on a three you
can just play rook captures on a three
and now let's say rook the b1 and that's
just it
yeah white is lost EU cannot move the
Queen whatever you do with the Queen you
could capture black screen but the rook
to h1 is mate because this bishop still
controls this diagonal so after this
rook characters on a3 you could also try
Queen captures and c6 but sorry after
rook captures on a3
now you might try Queen captures and c6
but it's still not better just rugby to
check and after the King moves to g1 now
you play rook captures here and yes you
can block with Bishop to see one but
just rook captures Queen captures and
again rook to be one wins the Queen so
it's a bishop against no pieces of
course completely winning for black and
also black is up to two points so of
course after rook captures an a3 Duda
gladly accepted the draw and it is
Alexander issue who wins the feeder
Grand Prix in Hamburg 2019 and as I've
heard he oh well most likely qualifies
for the candidates tournament but it all
depends on how the other players play as
well I guess in Jerusalem in the last
leg of the of the feeder Grand Prix so
but I it's like 99% percent that a
Grisha is in the feed a candidate
sternum in 2020 so we're gonna have a
very exciting tournament there and also
here is a nice footage of Sasha getting
up from the table and starting to
celebrate early
whereas Duda of course is very
disappointed but you know is there it
can only be one winner or only one
player gets to celebrate oh yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it again
story for so many videos today but
really it's not my fault we do have to
cover all of the interesting games for
such such an important finals so I I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Praveen rajendran Jimmy Thomas and
unleash Srinivasa for a contribution to
my channel thank you I really appreciate
it as usual you can check to my previous
videos here think all for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions and
hopefully we will be is that will will
start a vote on our next big saga let's
say tomorrow and then
I might not even make any videos
tomorrow since we made so many today so
we'll see how it goes
soon thank y'all I will see soon and
have an excellent rest of your Sunday